the person I admire the most is the
people that have so much adversity and
not a peep of complaining about dumb
[__] I watch people walk around this
Earth every day complain about they
don't have the milk type that they want
on their seven dollar coffee the Uber is
late by two minutes which is a profound
technology the Wi-Fi didn't work on the
plane this time as if they're entitled
to that I think we complain about a lot
of dumb [__] and so the people that
inspire me are the people that nobody
talks about these people that I see four
and five in the morning who aren't Elon
Musk quarant Jeff Bezos who aren't Oprah
these people are grinding that put their
family on their back and [__] work to
try to make it better for their family
and have no capacity to complain about
it